[Música]
en primera plana
carlos semana
[Música]
bienvenidos a en primera plana un
programa de radio france internacional
de france 24 por cierto nuestro primer
en primera plana de 2022 feliz año a
todos y para empezar el año y vamos a
analizar la presidencia francesa que
acaba de comenzar cuando en 2022 de la
unión europea nos acompañan en este
estudio marc va a ser corresponsal del
país en francia bienvenido marc hola
muchas gracias eulalia rubio
investigadora del instituto de jacques
delors especialista en asuntos
económicos europeos bienvenida al
allianz y en dúplex desde bruselas
nuestra corresponsal esther herrera este
es buenos días hola buenos días la
presidencia francesa de la unión europea
hoy nuestro asunto en primera plana
[Música]
francia recoge el testigo de la
presidencia semestral rotatoria de la
unión europea y aunque los planes de
macrón se resuman en el objetivo de
lograr una europa soberana y autónoma
estratégicamente a nadie se le escapa
que esta presidencia coincide plenamente
con las elecciones en abril aquí en
francia para elegir el nuevo inquilino
del elíseo para muchos la influencia de
macrón en europa se hace ahora más
evidente todavía después de que se haya
ido la ex canciller alemana angela
merkel pero obviamente no se consolidará
como tal si no es de nuevo elegido
presidente de francia repasemos algunas
portadas que nos deja la prensa respecto
a este asunto diario libération muestra
ese macrón que se asume presidente de
europa y a la vez macrón en campaña un
doble rol del que hoy hablaremos en el
programa the economist habla de nuevo
orden europeo con macrón de protagonista
y francia impulsando a europa la opinión
de una forma más editorial macrón quiere
una europa al servicio de su candidatura
al elíseo bueno esta presidencia
semestral se produce yo diré en un
escenario cargado de significado donde
se superponen los planos no el plan
europeo con futuro político de francia
todo ello atravesado por el contexto de
la pandemia el del vacío que dejan que
la merkel y el de una agencia muy
ambiciosa muchos planos superpuestos
marquen no sé si pueden definir un punto
crucial para europa bueno por tus
cruciales para lo para más macro lo ha
dicho que el presente de grandes macro
que es este este año puede ser un
momento de giro de un punto de inflexión
para luego pero éste se dice siempre y
eso creo que el president europea y
quiere aprovechar perdón va a presidir
el consejo de la unión europea creo que
lo vamos a explicar pero esto le da un
cierto poder o margen para marcar la
agenda pero pero tampoco para decidir el
futuro de la unión europea y como dices
se mezcla con esta campaña intensa
cuatro meses de campaña y bueno y la
posibilidad de que macro no gane las
elecciones no salga reelegido con lo que
esta presidencia que pie que la empieza
europea que la empieza macrón la termine
otro presidente proceso porque son seis
meses termina en junio sólo seis meses y
vamos a explicar eulalia nuestros
oyentes espectadores de américa latina
que no estarán realizados con el tema en
qué consiste esa presencia del consejo
de la unión europea esa presidencia
rotatoria y hasta qué punto es
influyente y qué tareas tiene vamos a
explicar un poco si de hecho cada seis
meses hay un país de la unión europea
que preside el consejo de la unión
europea que es la reunión de los estados
miembros a nivel a nivel de presidentes
y primeros ministros se llama consejo
europeo y a nivel de ministros hay
diferentes consejos de la unión europea
por tema de economía de interior
etcétera antes del tratado de lisboa
en la presentación rotatoria la más
importante porque era la presidenta la
presidencia rotatoria que decidía un
poco el orden del día y los trabajos del
consejo que es uno de los organismos
importantes de la unión europea ahora
tenemos un presidente permanente de
misión entonces las presidencias
semestrales no tienen tanto peso tienen
que trabajar en tándem con el presidente
del consejo de la unió europea y no
tienen tanto peso como tenían antes por
ejemplo la última presidencia en francia
que de sarkozy era antes de los dolores
boa y el presidente sarkozy en este
momento tenía mucho más poder y más
discreción en decidir la agenda del
consejo de la unión europea
vamos a irnos hasta bruselas estamos en
directo con nuestra corresponsal con
esther herrera que lo primero es
cuéntanos que se espera y en bruselas de
esta presidencia francesa siempre que un
país grande asume la presidencia
rotatoria del consejo de la unión
europea hay grandes esperanzas ocurrió
con alemania en 2020 que salió muy
airosa en plena explosión de la pandemia
y vuelva a ocurrir ahora con francia
tendrá una agenda cargada como sacar
adelante las políticas medioambientales
hay que empezar a aprobar las leyes que
impulsen la reducción de emisiones
contaminantes de aquí a 2030 la
regulación la regularización de los
gigantes tecnológicos así como la eterna
asignatura pendiente que es la de la
gestión de la migración pero es
importante recalcar que la presencia
francesa no significa que francia vaya a
ser la única fernández dentro de la
unión europea sino que asume un rol de
gestión de liderazgo en que se pueden
influir en ciertas políticas dando
prioridad a unas y no a otras pero ya no
es el papel que tenían antes los países
como hace 14 años cuando francia asumió
la presión encía por última vez
pero 2022 debe suponer un momento de
cambio de rumbo europeo es lo que dijo
macrón en su discurso de fin de año la
reforma de las reglas fiscales ahora
temporalmente suspendidas por la
pandemia será el debate político central
durante este periodo que se abre el
margen legislativo de la presencia es
limitado lo hablamos antes con eulalia
pero mccrone ha dejado claro que su
prioridad política es la reforma del
pacto de estabilidad como parte del
desarrollo de la soberanía estratégica
de nerón europea él considera que hay
ciertas normas en este sentido que son
anacrónicas marc con qué escollos y con
qué apoyos va a encontrarse macrón y
cómo vamos a valorar que esta
presidencia sea un éxito hasta con qué
elementos bueno el pacto de estabilidad
para resumir un poco no las normas que
ese no le hicieron para que los países
del euro tuviesen una buena economía y
unos presupuestos más o menos
cuestionados y que establecen topes
límites de la deuda y del déficit el 3%
y antes de la pandemia si ya quedaron
suspendidos durante la pandemia y hay un
gran debate desde hace tiempo sobre si
esto se está estas estas normas hace 20
o 30 años
han quedado obsoletas y a mí me da la
sensación de que se está configurando un
cierto consenso a una de las ideas que
francia pone sobre la mesa pero también
países como españa o italia con draghi
que ha firmado hace nada aún una tribuna
con el propio macrón si es que europa
necesita inversiones
cuantiosas en algunos terrenos como el
medio ambiente o las nuevas tecnologías
siquiera europa a competir con potencias
como china o eeuu y si europa no quiere
quedar realmente en una posición
relevante en el siglo 21 y para invertir
en estos terrenos pues es necesario
flexibilizar estas normas que impedían o
que ponían límites al gasto público en
los países de la unión europea y de ahí
creo que esto liga directamente con la
idea de macrón pero no solo de más
grande de la autonomía estratégica de la
soberanía como como se quiera no pero de
la necesidad de que europa sea firme
como potencia cosa que por lo tanto está
bastante lejos de ocurrir
eulalia la valoración de la presencia
francesa de qué elementos va a depender
para que la consideremos un éxito o un
fracaso
es verdad como decía este que recordamos
ciertas presidencias la de alemania es
verdad que pequeños países que suelen
hacer buenos buenas presiones con
luxemburgo se le suele acreditar como
de la presidencia semestral en este caso
es una presidencia que está en un
momento que no es fácil brillar no es al
principio del mandato de la comisión
donde se tiene que establecer
la agenda legislativa no es como en el
caso de alemania en plena pandemia donde
teníamos necesidad de crear nuevas cosas
y de imaginación es una es una presencia
a mediados del mandato de la comisión
hay muchas cosas avanzadas que se tienen
que negociar entonces la capacidad de
hacer giros de introducir nuevos temas
es un poco limitada dicho esto es verdad
que francia tiene muchas ideas y que ha
puesto el acento en algunas cosas
también hay otros temas por ejemplo el
tema de las reglas presupuestales que la
vamos ahora francia tiene interés pero
también es difícil imaginar que llegarán
a un acuerdo y que se concluirá en la
presidencia francesa porque es un tema
muy difícil porque hay mucha
polarización porque hay los países
frugales que no están de acuerdo con la
visión del europeo del sur entonces lo
que va a intentar macrón es crear el
marco conceptual de esta nueva reforma y
por eso hay este consejo europeo a
principios de marzo para reflexionar
sobre el modelo o nuevo modelo de
crecimiento de inversión la idea de
macro no más
es crear un consenso sobre lo que
necesitamos en términos de reglas
presupuestarias pero igual no llegar a
un acuerdo detallado técnico de cómo
cambiar estas reglas esto seguramente
llegará a finales de año otro de los
grandes pilares de estas presidencias en
la europa de la defensa de la que vamos
a hablar luego en unos instantes pero
antes vamos a volver a bruselas con
esther herrera porque bueno el hecho de
que coincida esta esta presidencia con
la cita electoral de las presidenciales
francesas seguramente tampoco pase
desapercibido allí en bruselas este hay
miedo a interferencias de la realidad de
francia y esos planos superpuestos
distintos en los que se tiene que situar
el llamémosla si candidato presidente
sin duda el momento no es el ideal y es
verdad que aquí francia tendrá un
difícil papel de equilibrio entre sus
prioridades en el consejo de la unión
europea y en lo que quiere como país no
creo que manuel macro lo vaya a tener
fácil y es cierto que cualquier traspiés
puede afectarle en la campaña electoral
y al contrario los triunfos europeos
pueden hacerle ganar votos pero aquí de
nuevo también tiene que ser el cauteloso
es verdad qué macrón siempre ha sido un
entusiasta europeísta pero aquí tendrá
que jugar bien sus cartas porque las
elecciones en francia son la gran cita
electoral del año pero tiene seis meses
de presidencia rotatoria muy importantes
en que francia será juzgada con lupa
bueno hasta ahora marm akrón no ha
querido anunciar oficialmente su
candidatura al elíseo seguramente lo
haga a finales de este mes es algo que
se da ya por descontado como ve este
doble rol del candidato presidente es q
podemos hablar es doblar si es
complicado porque por ejemplo si miramos
su papel como el papel de francia la
presidencia del consejo de la unión
europea a la vez tiene que ser un
árbitro más o menos neutral
y a la vez macro tendrá que
presentarse antes electorado como
alguien que defiende los intereses
franceses y sus adversarios rivales en
las campañas estarán pendientes de la
mínima concesión que pueda hacer o que
vaya en detrimento de los supuestos
intereses de francia al mismo tiempo es
verdad macrón hace cinco años ganó a las
elecciones con un mensaje europeísta muy
europeísta muy clara en sus mítines sus
seguidores se veían más banderas
europeas que francesas lo cual les es
bastante insólito y más en estos tiempos
de nacionalismos de repliegues de oro
escepticismo break 7 etcétera etcétera y
ahí hay una especie casi de justicia
poética en el hecho de que la reelección
llegue en el momento en que francia está
frente al consejo de la unión europea
porque
como decía ganó con una europea y ahora
se la va a jugar de nuevo con la europea
que yo creo que es en el fondo es el
buscásemos que es el macro nismo y que
es la ideología maquinista
el núcleo de todo esto está el
europeísmo el europeísmo y luego les
quiero preguntar precisamente por esa
relación entre europeísmo y macro nismo
puede servirse macrón de la presidencia
semestral como una plataforma para su
campaña eulalia yo creo que sí yo creo
que lo intenta y lo intentará de hecho
macrón o francia hubiera podido pedir
cambiar el momento de la elección
atrasar la presidencia semestral y
cambiarla con otro país y no lo hizo en
el fondo el análisis detrás y la idea
detrás era que le podía servir a macro
porque precisamente como decía marx
mccrone para macro en europa ha sido un
sujeto de campaña y lo que le interesa
macro ni yo creo que ahora con eso es
arrogarse este título de yo soy el
candidato europeísta en las en las
francesas la otra cosa a tener en cuenta
es que hablamos mucho del impacto de la
presidencia de la unión del conservador
y europea sobre las presidenciales pero
las presidenciales también tienen un
impacto en la forma en que francia
gestionará esta presidencia del consejo
de la unión europea y por ejemplo que
vemos en el calendario es que han tenido
que poner muchísimas cosas los primeros
meses porque muchas cosas quieren que
pasen antes de las elecciones sobre el
mes de enero pero están muy cargados con
muchas reuniones antes de que llegue el
marzo y abril- que habrá con una campaña
y ya ven como ha marcado la agenda
también política interna vamos a hacer
una breve pausa en estos instantes y
enseguida volvemos para seguir
analizando la presidencia francesa la
unión europea quien en primera plana
hasta ahora
hacia dónde va europa
cuál es su peso en la balanza global un
repaso a la actualidad de los 27 países
de la unión europea con reportajes y
entrevistas de nuestra corresponsal en
bruselas europa hoy en france 24 y
france 24 puntocom
[Música]
sus historias inspiran el futuro su día
a día es la actualidad su cultura sus
luchas sus éxitos y están en el corazón
de nuestros programas les contamos los
que hicieron américa latina y los que la
construyen hoy les contamos un mundo
hecho día a día por los que lo habitan
liberté égalité actual y ti
seguimos en primera plan esta semana
analizando la presidencia francesa
rotatoria de la unión europea lo hacemos
con marc bazanne corresponsal del país
hebreo rubio investigador del instituto
jacques delors y nuestra corresponsal en
bruselas esther herrera dice esta semana
el cv gigantes nacional en su portada la
presidencia del exceso expresando sus
dudas sobre la omnipresencia de macrón
en todos los frentes marc hay algo de
excesivo en esta presidencia que puede
ser contraproducente tanto para europa
como para macrón
bueno como comentábamos ahora hubiese
podido macro en renunciar a esta
presidencia o
colocarla en otro momento ha querido
asumir el presidente yo creo que la
presidencia francesa ya no europea pero
francesa por definición es excesiva al
sistema francés la constitución francesa
del 58 la quinta república otorga al
presidente unos poderes enormes que
ningún otro jefe de estado de gobierno
tiene en un gran país es un punto de
monarca tiene un punto de monarca el
monarca republicano como como se ha
dicho y por lo tanto todos los
presidentes o casi todos
a
ocupar este espacio de una manera a
veces excesiva y
esto dice el corriente nacional
presiente que acumula a todas las
presidencias gracias ganancias de europa
no no es no no me parece anómalo y
tampoco con la personalidad de macro que
es un presiente que se puede decir que
tímido no es y tiene este punto de
audacia de riesgo y de insensatez de
querer hacerlo todo ir a por todas y
arriesgarse porque hay una parte de de
riesgo en esta mezcla de géneros que
vamos a presenciar en los próximos
cuatro meses de campaña electoral muy
intensa y un punto salvaje en francia y
a la vez presidencia institucional del
consejo de europea hay un riesgo para la
marca y para europa también no sé si
coincido en ese riesgo que puede bueno
bastante en la visión de marca en el
sentido de que yo diría más es que las
presidencias francesas del consejo del
on europea son excesivas en general no
son son muy marcadas francia es un país
que le gusta marcar a europa que tiene
una idea muy clara y que toma la
iniciativa no es un país que le gusta
gestionar el día a día le gusta poner
sus ideas de europa
y si pensamos en la presidencia del star
cruise y del 2008 fue un poco así
también y hubo un montón de eventos un
montón de reuniones y sarkozy
intensificó su actividad europea durante
el semestre que le tocó es bastante
francés también en parte eso
vamos a irnos de nuevo hasta bruselas
esther la reforma de schengen y la
europa de la defensa son dos de los
proyectos más ambiciosos de la
presidencia europea o comentábamos antes
con eulalia todo ese programa con casco
yo suelo encontrar francia los dos son
proyectos muy complejos pero a la vez
muy macrón ya nos en el sentido que
estos dos siempre han sido sus
prioridades así que no es ninguna
sorpresa para sus socios europeos sobre
la defensa se quiera avanzar más en la
creación de este pequeño cuerpo de cinco
mil soldados esta acción rápida para
actuar en lugares donde la unión europea
tenga intereses y también la conocida
como autonomía estratégica esto de que
europa de mi prenda más de sí misma y
menos de eeuu aquí pronto se puede ver
con la oposición de los países del este
con polonia los países bálticos a la
cabeza que insiste en que la otan ya es
la alianza militar y no se necesitan
duplicidades sobre la reforma de
schengen es abrir también la caja de
pandora aquí puede tener el apoyo de
países muy duros con la migración como
por ejemplo hungría pero habrá gas hasta
qué punto puede afectar a países que
reciben migrantes como españa italia que
a menudo han lamentado que francia no
les ha apoyado lo suficiente en la
gestión de la migración la gestión de la
migración y los problemas desde 2015 que
sufre el espacio schengen que permite la
libertad de circulación de las personas
no es algo de lo que se puede salir
airoso así que francia tiene el plato
aquí quizás más fuerte y difícil de su
presidencia porque los países están muy
divididos
respecto a las reglas fiscales francia
un país partidario de que se apliquen
con flexibilidad las normas utilizará su
presidencia para intentar hacer avanzar
sus posiciones con la ayuda de italia no
en vano lo comentaba antes el propio
macro ni el primer ministro italiano
mario draghi acaban de publicar un
artículo conjunto en el diario británico
financial times dejando clara su
posición
no sé si creen que se consolida
eje franco italiano es mucho decir
porque es mucho se viene hablando de
esta cuestión nosotros tenemos tiempos
marc bueno no sé si se puede hablar de
eje pero sí que se
reconfiguran un poco las alianzas
también después de que angela merkel
dejase la cancillería alemana
y a partir de ahí terceros países que
son siempre evocamos italia y españa-
que intentan buscar ese peso mayor sí y
después a ver es verdad antes ha
mostrado la portada al economista en la
que aparecía de manuel macrón con quien
el líder de europa pero hay otro líder
de europa que es mario draghi que por la
experiencia es un senior podríamos decir
que es una es un hombre de estado con
una carrera acreditada sobre todo
central banco central europeo donde
desempeña un papel histórico en la
última en la última década y yo creo que
macrón busca el abrigo de draghi la
credibilidad de draghi macro por es más
relevante influyen del presidente de la
república francesa que el primer
ministro italiano y dada la
inestabilidad italiana no sabemos en un
mes son unos meses donde estará draghi
pero pero draghi tiene ésta
credibilidad y está en esta trayectoria
que a makro le conviene buscar su
alianza yo diría que el liderazgo
europeo y está entre varios draghi
evidentemente olaf scholz en alemán
también quizás los países rurales
realidad desconfían bastante de este
nuevo eje formado
vamos a ver qué pasa también porque
este año si se presenta o no como
presidente pero si tenemos que tener en
cuenta lo que pasa con las salidas
presupuestarias sobre todo lo importante
es saber qué pasará con los países
frugales y como decía mark el peso de
alemania alemania es el actor clave en
este en este sentido porque tenemos las
dos coaliciones en los países del sur
que son para una reforma que de más más
más margen para la inversión pública y
los países del norte que siempre son más
para una reforma que refuerce las reglas
y los límites a la deuda y al déficit y
alemania es la que juega un poco tenemos
que ver un poco ahí esta obertura ahora
con el nuevo con el nuevo gobierno de
alemán que parece un poco más abierto
y más proclive a aceptar que necesitamos
más inversión pública y ahí es donde
francia necesita
liberal en el gobierno alemán que no
dice exactamente lo mismo aire todavía
en medida que piden que haya más
inversión que necesitamos una inversión
para sostener esta transición climática
esto puede ayudar a macro no sea que yo
creo que lo crucial para arreglos
presupuestarios es encontrar el acuerdo
con alemania vamos a preguntarle
precisamente sobre esta cuestión a
nuestra corresponsal en bruselas la
salida de merkel es a su vez un espacio
seguro difícil de cubrir en el que macro
podría ganar espacio pero también otros
terceros como italia o españa como se
percibe allí en bruselas esta
circunstancia esther el vacío que ha
dejado angela merkel es sin duda visible
pero también es una litera la que se ha
criticado porque no he hecho suficiente
por ejemplo con hungría y polonia o
sobre su gestión durante la crisis de
refugiados que provocó grandes problemas
de divisiones entre los países y que aún
siguen coleando pero el vacío que deja
me puede ser también una nueva etapa
para tejer nuevas alianzas entre los
países como españa italia aunque es sin
duda
siempre será alemania y el eje
franco-alemán seguirá siendo elemental
en la unión europea pero a menudo sobre
merkel se dice que era una buena gestora
pero no era una fuerza revolucionador
ahí quizás eso es lo que necesita europa
ahora mismo ese cambio de tuerca ese
plus para ser innovadora si no quiere
caer en la irrelevancia en el mundo y
aquí si emanuel el macro en canadá a las
elecciones podría ser fundamental
otro asunto la polémica más interno pero
que tiene que ver con europa la polémica
de las banderas la polémica sobre la
conveniencia de una bandera europea
dónde en un monumento de alta
sensibilidad patriótica como es el arco
del triunfo aquí en parís ya se ha visto
en estos primeros compases de la
presidencia con gritos de traición de la
ultraderecha de parte también de la
derecha y también con la izquierda de
milán son entrando en la polémica e
incluso el candidato comunista diciendo
que para muchos el símbolo de
deslocalizaciones desindustrialización y
de pérdida de soberanía la bandera
europea bueno es una polémica pero más
allá de lo anecdótico es sintomática
esta polémica de cómo respira el país
marc si francia es un país muy dividido
sobre la unión europea yo pienso que es
gran bretaña el reino unido y ha salido
con el blake sí pero que después de
reino unido es uno de los países más
euroescépticos no hay que olvidar que en
francia se votó no al tratado
constitucional de la europea en 2005 que
el tratado de maastricht se aprobó por
muy poco en francia y que en las últimas
elecciones presidenciales llegó a la
segunda vuelta y sacó más de 10 millones
de votos
the independent que proponía la salida
de francia de la europea y del euro
ahora corregido está esta posición ya no
hay es verdad que ya no hay ningún
partido ningún candidato a las
presidenciales de abril que abiertamente
opte por el llamado flex y que serían lo
que fue el pre existió no pero francés
pero sí que es un país con un
sentimiento soberanista nacionalista
euroescéptico muy arraigado y creo que
lo que hizo macrón al colocar sólo la
bandera europea en el arco del triunfo
tenía un trasfondo y una idea de marcar
las diferencias
de marcar a la polarización entre los
europeístas y el asume la bandera
europea desde hace tiempo que ganó las
elecciones como decíamos con la bandera
europea y los euroescépticos y un poco
empujar a candidatos que compiten con él
como valerie pécresse que es la cantidad
del centro de la derecha de la derecha
pero derecha moderada en la extrema
derecha y de tradición muy europeísta
pero valérie pécresse acabó criticando
esta decisión con lo que macrón esto muy
táctica táctica electoral es tacticismo
de corto plazo en realidad pero
empujarla hacia el campo de los
euroescépticos y quedarse quedarse
macrón como el único europeísta fíjense
qué juego tan fino de no sé si podremos
decir el macro mismos hoy por hoy
eulalia sinónimo en francia de quienes
defienden el multilateralismo y el
europeísmo nítidamente o le voy a hacer
la buena pregunta de otra forma
formulada es complicado ser europeísta
en francia y buscar otras opciones que
tengan peso criticando macrón no tendría
que ser eso es peligroso pensar que en
un país bellísimo dependa de una persona
de una corriente política es decir
no tendría que ser el caso y hasta ahora
no ha sido en francia ha habido hay una
parte muy importante del escepticismo
pero la derecha moderada y la izquierda
moderada siempre ha sido pro europeísta
entonces macro juega hacia ser el
candidato europeísta y le interesa para
ganar las elecciones para eso para su
futuro le interesa que se vea así que se
asocie europeísmo con macro nismo pero
por el país en sí yo no creo que sea una
buena cosa la buena cosa sería que fuera
más consensual y más
repartido entre diferentes partidos en
la bandera europea pero evidentemente la
polémica de la bandera de arco de
triunfo es una polémica que ayuda a
macro en este sentido de arrogarse esta
visión de georges soy el candidato que
defiende europa y los otros candidatos
no los no defienden a europa y
justamente el hecho que para el clip te
crees un poco se pusiera al campo
también de los que criticaban la bandera
le ha ayudado más grandes que porque
hasta ahora les decía yo también soy una
candidata de europa yo también estoy por
europa entonces pero si es un juego
peligroso para francia no solo para más
no para para chrome para francia porque
si sólo depende de un candidato europa
entonces qué pasa si se gana el auto no
gana nos quedamos sin nada sin estas
incógnitas las vamos a ir resolviendo
poco a poco hasta el mes de abril cuando
tengamos las elecciones presidenciales a
quien francia muchísimas gracias a los 2
marc eulalia y también a esther desde
bruselas y a todos ustedes les esperamos
aquí la próxima semana quien en primera
plana muchas gracias
[Música]